You know..
There's such a negative connotation
about being alone.
Hey, loner!
Or should we say LOSER~?
Or should we say both?
(syncronized giggle)
And yet, spending time by yourself
is how we figure out who we are
and what we really love.
Lately..
I've been feeling really shitty
about being alone.
Like, should I be surrounded
by people?
Is there something wrong with me?
Is it weird that I don't have a lot
of friends?
But, I've come to the conclusion
that it's the idea of being alone
that bugs me a lot more than
ACTUALLY being alone.
Because, taking yourself to
the movies, is amazing.
And have you ever gone to dinner solo?
It's a whole new experience!
I actually used to take myself out
on a date every week,
whether it was to Barnes and Nobles,
or a thrift store,
or even just window shopping for cats.
Hanging out by yourself
can be so much fun.
And yet, it's looked down upon.
You see someone who's alone,
and you're like, "Oh, you're so lonely."
You know what I mean?
It's thought of as like, sad.
When it doesn't have to be, and in fact
it's probably really healthy for you!
When I was a teenager, I always
used to fantasize about the day I
met my significant other.
I was like, "Oh, we're gonna be best
friends and partners in crime and
we're gonna have a ball!"
And then as I grew up, and experienced
relationships, I would always stumble.
Because I failed to realize that..
if I don't like hanging out with myself,
why would anyone else?
So, I encourage you to give it a try.
Take yourself out on a date this week.
Challenge accepted, accepted.
I mean, it can be scary.
And weird, and you might feel lonely,
but, I think in the end, you'll be really
proud of yourself for at least giving it a shot.
Who knows?
You might get lucky.
No, I don't think masturbation counts.
Although it is technically healthy.
So, the other day, I walked in on THIS:
Are those my first edition Watchmen
comics out of the plastic?!
You said I could read them..
That's what the $20 compilation booklet is for!
What the fu--!